When we read the last and final
revelation of the glorious Quran, when I
say this life is a test for the
hereafter, what are the guidelines of
this test? If you read surah al assur
chapter number 103, it is called as rah
nijad the path to salvation, the path to
ja. It says in surah al assur chapter
number 103 verse number 1
to3 by the token of time Allah is taking
the oath of
time verily man is in a state of
loss except those who have
faith those who have righteous
deed those who invite people to truth do
dawa those who invite people to patience
and perseverance. So according to surah
al assur man is in kasara every human
being will go to hell
except those who have these four
criteria. Number one
im
number righteous deed number one faith
number two righteous deed number
three inviting people to truth doing
dawa inviting people to patience and
perseverance. If any one of these four
criteria is missing, you shall not enter
Jenna. You may be a very good Muslim.
You may be praying five times a day. You
may be fasting in the month of Ramadan.
You may have gone for Hajj. You may have
the mark on your forehead. But if you
don't do dawa according to surah assur,
you shall not enter Jenna. If Allah
wants to forgive you and put you in
Jenna, that's Allah's prerogative. But
under normal circumstances, all four are
equally important. Not only dawa, I im
righteous
deed, inviting people to truth and
inviting people to patience and pursue.
All four are equally important.
According to Imam Shafi, may Allah have
mercy on him. He said that if Surah
Alsar alone was revealed for humanity,
it would have been sufficient for
guidance. Imagine the great Imam. If
surah al Assur was revealed
alone not the full Quran only surah alas
three verses it is the second shortest
surah in the Quran. If this was revealed
alone it would have been sufficient for
haya for guidance for humanity. There
was a person a Jewish beggar at the time
of Hafnadaras Kalani and we know from
the books of history that half Kalani he
was a
judge and he was quite affluent and
rich. So this poor Jewish man goes and
asks him that I heard that a prophet
said that this dunya this
world for the believers is a prison and
for the unbelievers it is paradise. How
can you justify I am a beggar my clothes
are torn. You are such a rich man. You
are a Muslim. I am a non-Muslim. How can
this world be a paradise for me and a
prison for you?
Had Kalani he
replied and this hadith that the Jewish
beggar quoted is from Sai Muslim volume
number seven had number
7417 and half
Kalani may Allah have mercy on him he
said that the Muslim knows that in the
next life he's going to get Jenna and if
he knows what Jenna is in this world
even if you're the richest man. This
life is like prison compared to the next
life. Even if you're the richest man,
even if you're the king, if you know
what is awaiting you for
Jenna, this world is nothing. Not even
0.00001% compared to
Akara. That's the reason those who truly
know
Islam, what they want, they want to go
to Jenna fast. They're not afraid of
death. The end of death
why if a human being is on the straight
path of sarat of sural ass if he dies he
goes to Jenna so who would not like to
hasten to die you cannot kill ourselves
it's haram suicide is haram but of
course in the way of Allah if you're on
the hak you're not afraid you aren't
afraid of anyone if you're on the hak a
true
Muslim if he's on the he's not afraid of
death because if he dies he goes to
paradise even if he's the richest man in
the world even if he's 10 times richer
than Bill Gates Alon Musk and Jeff Bess
all Nothing.